- You deserve some congrats as well.
You're a daddy now.
- Yep.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah.
That's so exciting.
(audience cheering)
It's the first time you've been on here
since you've been a daddy.
- It's pretty wild.
Yeah, there she is.
- Yes.
- She's got a little heart face.
- A little heart face.
- And she's the best.
It's just been a magical
season of our life
and you know, also pretty wild,
but it it's a blessing to have her home.
And been wonderful.
Lots of and you have a lot to celebrate.
- [Kelly] I do, yeah.
- Nine, is it nine?
- Our show got nine Emmys.
(audience cheering)
We're so fun.
- This calls for a toast.
- Are we gonna drink?
I love when we drink on my show.
- Yeah, we always drink on your show.
- Okay, okay.
Oh, wait.
Okay, y'all had fabulous drinks
at your house when I came
so wait, is this your?
- It's the same thing we drank.
- Is this your tequila?
- This is tequila.
- This is good.
(audience cheering)
- [Nick] Just seems right.
- It just feels like home.
Just, it's so good.
- [Nick] It's so good.
- It's fancy fantastic
with this little number.
- Little blood orange just
really elevates the drink.
- I just had to drink again
to make sure I liked it.